oh yeah i got arrested like four times
dumb [ __ ] like uh one was i got arrested
for getting naked in an emergency room
one night just this chick that was
always into soccer is kind of like into
us and my other roommate comes in dude
we gotta go chad just broke his finger
running up the stairs and i go dude i'm
i got i'm staying
five minutes later my buddy chatted with
the broker finger comes in he goes you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you're gonna stay
for some [ __ ] we get to the emergency
room and i'm starting to get angry that
i'm not at the party i go you know what
[ __ ] it
i get stark naked i go come on we're
dancing come on the nurse wants to dance
with me and we see blue and red lights
which one of you pieces of [ __ ] got
naked in this hospital i go someone got
naked
disrespect
and then we show up to court i have a
report here that says mr verzi exposed
his bear buttocks in the little falls
emergency room
when asked why are you naked
mr verzi's reply was my belt buckle came
undone